is that a thing are we making that
happen
hashtag can't see oh yeah another deal
yeah I want to play a quick game with
you guys see ncor pretty much I'm gonna
read you a sentence you just answer if
it's pretty much or if it's ciencia who
pulls more pranks on set pretty much
because we have fun over here yeah yeah
be honest have you pulled any good
pranks lately yeah he's the prank yeah
yeah what do you do increase we always
feel like a lot of pranks to them one
time I remember I put 2 to reach our end
and we thought that it was it was we
both did it because we were saying rooms
at that time and this guy just sneaked
in the room and just like put soap
around a toothbrush and I thought it was
him and he thought that I did it and
then we were both like oh what was going
on all friendly roll I hope you're
working on revenge
yeah we're we're we're kind of analyzing
Massachusetts well coming
and I like changed into a cracked screen
like a broken screen click on the phone
and and I locked it back and put it next
to it and then I pretend knocked it over
off the thing onto a wooden floor and
she freed them yeah yeah that's what
lengths to get this film iPhones are not
cheap I'm sure she was not pleased no
who brings a bigger entourage on set
pretty much pretty much yeah what you
got with you not today but I don't
really ever seen their eyes can be
traveled with a whole squad it's not and
not like just like our team like people
to help is like we're talking like
sheiks friends and come over the crib
like we have about 10 15 I guess one
doesn't live here so I we can invite our
friends how many people who's more into
style and picking out the looks for a
shoot like this it's just different but
like they both everybody I'm hoping they
gave it to us too we both have a 3 in
the style how would you describe yours
versus theirs yeah Isis Street as well
but a little bit more I don't know Eddie
I guess who hangs out at craft services
more I'll take out of the remote in
pretty much was there smack of choice go
down the road
I'll find something pretzels chicks mix
green apples and me and I on like I was
good I was waiting for one person to
give me a a not healthy snack water our
Bruce thank you yeah oh yeah you need a
problem stunt work that you're doing out
there don't words no actually though I'm
like Bruce all the way I was like
hanging up in the air and I had to like
boys boys downstairs
[Music]